Sol Ring is a Magic: the Gathering card. It was
first printed in 1993 in Alpha, the first print
run of the first Magic: the Gathering set, and
went on to be printed in the other three print
runs, ending in Spring of 1994. It is one of the
most powerful mana artifacts in the game, and has
been banned or restricted in most constructed
formats for basically its entire existence.
It sat on the Reserved list, a list of cards that
Wizards of the Coast has promised not to reprint,
from 1996 until 2002 at which point Wizards
updated the reserved list to allow reprints
of the first set’s commons and uncommons.
The card commanded fairly high prices all
through the 2000s, with it being reprinted
in the limited run From the Vault: Relics
but still keeping most of its value. Then, it
was printed in the first commander set in 2011,
as one of two cards included in all
five of the set’s preconstructed decks.
The other card was Command Tower,
effectively a downside-less Mana Confluence.
The reasoning for this choice
on Wizard’s part was simple:
Sol Ring was considered by some to be a
must-include in the then-small Commander format,
since, on account of it being banned in
legacy, its low-double-digits price being
pretty affordable for its powerful level. So,
the precon decks should also include Sol Ring.
I could say a lot about this logic—most
prominently that Sol Ring’s relative
affordability is a product of it not being played
in large formats. Printing sets specifically for
EDH was a great way to inflate the size of that
format, a process which, without a reprint,
would have caused a demand spike with a fixed
supply and increased the price, likely relegating
Sol Ring to higher power level EDH decks. It’s
a problem that solves itself, one could argue.
Also, the precon commander decks weren’t exactly
well-constructed, so the idea that they needed
to keep up with the decks of longtime
commander players is pretty laughable. But
something you might notice is that there’s a small
difference between me and Wizards of the Coast—I
don’t make money off of how many units of the
commander precons decks get sold. And they do.
So, I guess I’m a little biased that way.
But okay, I think it would have been fine, or even
advisable, to let Sol Ring’s price soar as the
format’s size grows—let it be a toy for the power
gamers, alongside Mana Crypt, Moxen, and the like.
I understand why some people might
disagree, but that’s my opinion.
There are also people who have argued
that it should be banned, such as a
writer known as Chizarlicious two months after
the commander set’s release in 2011. And well,
unless somebody goes around burning every single
copy of Sol Ring on Earth released after 2010,
a ban would really be the only solution. But it’s
not going to happen. Commander’s ban list is,
hot take alert, kind of a stupid mess that very
clearly underscores the difficulty of moderating
such a large format played in so many different
ways and with such a wide potential pool of cards.
On top of this, Sol Ring has been printed
in over a dozen commander sets. Wizards have
done their utmost to place the card within the
pantheon of EDH. So, Sol Ring is here to say.
But what does that mean for the
game? What does the existence
of wildly powerful cards at a cheap
price do to a format like commander?
One of the most compelling issues with these
cheap, powerful cards is that they warp the
way that players look at other cards. Depending
on the goals of a deck and how it’s constructed,
it might be looking for varying quantities of mana
rocks, counter spells, draw spells, and so on.
You could build a framework for the deck without
looking at cards, for example going “okay,
this deck wants eight ramp spells, ten
draw spells, and twelve removal spells.
I should look through cards to
find these quantities of cards.”
But c’mon, let’s be honest. This
is not how most people build decks.
People see their options for ramp, draw,
and removal, and just start adding cards.
The specific cards being considered then have
an impact on how many of that sort of card end
up in the final deck. As a counter-scenario, one
can imagine a universe in which players’ removal
options solely consist of Naturalize,
Murder, Lava Coil, and Banishing Light,
to be played in whatever quantities the player
wants. In this universe, a player is forced to
spend more time thinking about questions like
“how much am I worried about enchantments and
artifacts? How many creature removal spells do I
need to deal with opposing pressure and wincons?”
The question isn’t what specific removal a player
needs, but rather how much of these stock options.
Back in the real world, things end up
working out a bit different than this.
This is especially pronounced if a player is using
a website like EDHRec, or some other metric that
orders cards by popularity or quality. If you’re
looking for counterspells in scryfall ordered
by EDHRec rank, as I have been spotted doing
from time to time, you first see Counterspell,
a card that’ll set you back a dollar.
Great, love it. Then you see a couple of
other options that are similar with a downside,
as well as a couple that cost a lot of money.
By the time you get down to your standard
staples, your kitchen table kings,
your modern machinations of yore, it’s looking
a lot less tempting. You have your Mana Leak
type cards that fall off in power fast in later
turns, you have your more specialized options,
and then you have your counterspells that
commit the cardinal sin of costing three mana.
It’s easy to imagine a player, seeing the rapid
price increases and power decreases that happen
when you scroll downward from Counterspell,
going “well okay, I guess I’ll run Counterspell
and a couple of these other ones, and then I’ll
have the good counterspells within my budget.”
Now, it should be mentioned that
Counterspell is an incredibly powerful card.
Most other counter options that
players can run are worse than it, yes,
but I’d guess that most blue decks want
lowercase-c counterspells enough that they’d
benefit from running cards that are kind of a lot
worse than counterspell. A joke in my playgroup is
to respond to the question of “oh what does that
card do?” with something like “oh yeah it’s like a
worse Sol Ring” or “oh yeah it’s basically a worse
version of Lightning Bolt.” The joke here is that
these statements tell you almost nothing about the
actual power of a card; it’s like somebody asking
how old a person is you saying “oh yeah, they’re
younger than Henry Kissinger.” Helpful, thank you.
As a point of contrast, we can consider other
types of cards somebody might choose to run,
ones whose power is less obvious.
It’s pretty easy to go “oh, Wizard’s Retort?
That’s strictly worse than Counterspell.”
But what about if I want, say, a card that
generates value when I play creature spells?
Alright… scryfall… let’s go green cards that have
“whenever”, “cast”, and “creature” in their text,
and let’s rank them based on EDHRec, and… there.
Well okay, so there’s Beast Whisperer, and
there’s The Great Henge, and there’s Silverback
Elder, and there’s Primeval Bounty, and there’s
Glimpse of Nature, and there’s Wild Pair, and
there’s Masked Admirers, and there’s Vengevine.
So which ones here are the bad ones? Which ones
should I add, and where should I stop adding here?
These cards are pulled from all across the 57
ordered cards that pop up with my search inputs.
Some are more flexible or more
bursty or lower to the ground,
but analyzing them is a much trickier value
proposition than looking at counterspells.
It’s possible I did the math on my deck ahead of
time and gone “okay, I need two or three of these
cards, preferably at least one in the 4-5 mana
range and at least one in the 6-7 mana range.”
But if I didn’t… gee, there sure are
a lot of good looking cards here…
I could run worse Counterspell or worse
Sol Ring, or… I could run more of these.
And counter spells aren’t the only thing to get
neglected. If I’m looking for creature removal,
Swords to Plowshares and Path to Exile are
both under two bucks and absurdly powerful,
with other white creature removal being
much worse or much more expensive.
If I’m looking for artifact removal,
Red has Abrade and Vandalblast,
with other options once again
being much worse or more expensive.
If I’m looking for general purpose draw for
blue, there are a few low budget options—Mystic
Remora is fabulous, especially with its price
halved by a Dominaria Remastered reprint,
and Mulldrifter, Treasure Cruise, and Archmage
Emeritus all have decent spots in several
different archetypes. But beyond that, things
get weaker, more specialized, or more expensive.
If somebody isn’t setting out a framework
for their deck, it’s easy to imagine
under-doing it on the more generalist stuff
and overdoing it on the more synergistic stuff.
And a deck running too much synergistic
stuff and not enough general stuff is
at risk of getting itself into a bimodal
pickle—a state where it either falls on
its face after getting a key piece removed,
or it goes on a mach 10 march toward victory.
A basic issue with having cards like Sol Ring
widely available is that card quality in a
given deck gets a lot less consistent at lower
budgets. If you’re building a deck with a budget
in the high hundreds or more, you might include
Counterspell alongside Mana Drain and a couple
other pricy counters, along with whichever cheaper
ones best fit your deck and play situations.
If you needed some green ramp, you also might
include Nature’s Lore, along with Three Visits,
a clone from Portal Three Kingdoms, a set that
was almost exclusively sold in East Asian markets.
Until a series of reprints recently, the only
way to get this card was to pay upwards of $50
for the P3K version. And honestly P3K could be
a video topic on its own, but I’m not going to
dwell on it further today. All this to say,
shelling out money leads to deck consistency.
There are certainly powerful cards that are cheap
due to wide reprints or another reason, such as
Sol Ring, Counterspell, and Swords to Plowshares,
but there’s an even sneakier type of budget card:
the ones that cost $0. A quick anecdote—I recently
built a Meria, Scholar of Antiquity deck. It’s an
equipments deck—you throw a bunch of equipments
on Meria and then tap them to generate mana and
value. I kind of built it as a meme but it’s a
genuinely delightful mid-power-level aggro deck.
Anyway, after ordering the $40 worth of mostly
random bulk I needed for the list, I sat staring
at the Sword of the Animist and the Sword of
Forge and Frontier I had in my collection.
They cost no money to add and would be so good in
the deck. I put them in the deck for a few games,
but they had such a warping effect that
I decided to take them out. My deck’s
mana and value engines were pretty solid for an
aggro deck, but decidedly reasonable in scope.
While Explorer’s Scope and Rogue’s Gloves
both feel very appropriate within the list,
when I played Sword of Forge and Frontier
it felt like a totally different deck, and I
know that the fact that that’s within the realm of
possibility naturally shifts the way my opponents
will think about my deck. Ultimately, it wasn’t
meant to be a particularly high-powered deck,
nor could it hope of performing like a high-power
deck on the current budget. So I cut the Swords.
The point being made here is that you should
add cards to a deck under consideration of how
they’ll impact the games you play with the deck,
even if you own them and they’re free to add.
My quasi-meme equipments deck has a handful of
specific weaknesses, and adding power cards to the
deck doesn’t help it manage those weaknesses with
any consistency, it just makes people wanna play
better decks against it. An even better example
is graveyard decks. Graveyard synergies are
wide-ranging, fun, and potentially quite powerful,
but they exist within a game with a lot of really
heavy-duty graveyard hate. There are the options
like Tormod’s Crypt and Rest in Peace which
straightforwardly demolish graveyard strategies,
and even cards like Nihil Spellbomb and Bojuka Bog
which do so without even spending a card, with the
latter dodging counterspells on top of all that.
All this to say, decks heavily based around
graveyards need to make a decision—accept
the need to be resilient against this stuff,
usually by winning quickly or being loaded with
counters for the hate, or play at a power
level where these cards are less common.
This puts a lot of mid-power graveyard decks
in an awkward spot—adding stronger synergies
will lead to crushing unprepared decks even more
than before, but will still end up with getting
wholesale dunked on by hate-cards unless the
efficiency of the deck is vastly improved to
guarantee quicker or more abrupt wins. There’s
not necessarily a right or wrong answer here,
but my mantra is that if you don’t wanna play
higher power level, don’t play higher power level.
Another example of this is cheap infinite
combos—namely, Niv-Mizzet and Curiosity.
I’ve known people who went “well
this deck is running red and blue,
and I’ve got the cards sitting
right here, why not add them?”
If you’re purely looking to increase the power
level of your deck, this is fine logic, but adding
an infinite combo to your deck changes the whole
dynamic of the games once people know it’s there.
As a frequent enjoyer of aggro, I
often find myself asking the question
“how will each of my opponents be trying
to win the game?” If the answer goes from,
I dunno, drakes or something to an infinite
combo that requires very little setup,
I will be hitting that player with my
creatures, and they will deserve it.
As another anecdote about building decks
for the type of games you want to play,
my brother recently got his first commander
deck, a decently-built Jodah deck.
In a night with several EDH games, everybody
pulled out one of their more powerful lists
every game he played the Jodah deck, resulting in
games where he was doing a lot but also eating a
lot of removal spells and needing to deal with
a bunch of powerful nonsense from other people.
The games were close, but the only
game he actually won that night
was in a lower power level game
where he borrowed my Meria deck.
At the end of the night, he proclaimed that
he needed to build a lower power level deck.
To bring this scattered assortment of points back
down to Earth a little, let’s think about Sol Ring
once again. A player running a budget deck might
run the ever-powerful Sol Ring alongside Hedron
Archive, lockets, or other slower mana ramp.
Now let’s consider this effect for draw—they’re
running a single Consecrated Sphinx that
they happen to have in their collection
alongside cards like Treasure Cruise,
Blue Sun’s Zenith, and Body of Knowledge.
Add in a few other examples like this, and
it’s not hard to construct an outline for
their deck where 10% of the time they chain very
powerful cards and explode the entire table,
but most of the rest of the time their deck
performs on a much lower caliber. Some might
ask “well what’s the problem with this?”
And well, the answer to that is complicated,
because EDH is a complicated format with a
variety of different players and power levels,
and a format where table politics and the threat
perceptions of individual players play a key role.
In this environment, individual power cards
might not necessarily pose a problem—y’know,
in my playgroups, Sol Ring is looked at
with a minor eye roll, a “nice draw bro.”
If the Sol Ring player gets out of hand, you
hit them a bit and hopefully things calm down.
Commander is theoretically
a self-balancing format,
but the more inconsistently powerful a deck
becomes, the trickier it becomes for other
people to conceptualize the power level of that
deck. At a certain point, the self-balancing
will simply be people hitting your deck, or
picking a more powerful deck to begin with,
because they don’t wanna contend with the
puzzle box that you’re presenting them with.
This video was a little meandering, so let’s try
and recap some of the key points here. Sol Ring is
an absurdly strong card, and I kinda hate putting
it in my lower power decks, but it’s not going to
get banned, nor would banning it particularly
constitute some kind of fundamental good for
the format in my opinion. Counterspell is also a
very strong card, and absolutely shouldn’t be held
as a power-level baseline for counter spells,
even if the card is called, well, Counterspell.
If you’re looking for mana rocks, counterspells,
or really any other sort of supporting effect, you
should ideally think about how many of these sorts
of effects your deck needs before going looking,
or at least be careful while looking at cards. A
deck built with the tools it needs at a slightly
lower power level will perform well with much
more consistency than the deck that only picks the
strongest 3-4 cards for categories of card where
the deck is really looking for more like 8 or 10.
An additional point I could flesh out more at a
later date is that sometimes the strongest option
isn’t even the best for a deck. If I wanna drop
my 4 mana commander on curve as often as possible,
it might be correct to run some lower-power 1 and
2 drop mana ramp rather than Cultivate, Kodama’s
Reach, or Harrow. Similarly, some decks might
be much less worried about running 3 or 4 mana
counter spells if they’re cheaper or better suited
to the deck than the options that cost less mana.
Additionally, players should add cards to
their deck under consideration of how those
cards will fit into the sort of game they want
to play. I could add Torment of Hailfire to my
turbo-battlecruiser Glissa deck, and
that would probably make it stronger,
but my opponents are going to view the deck wildly
differently if they know I have an I-win button.
Playing a truly absurd number of lands is the
goal of the deck and the fun part of the deck,
and I don’t want people to feel like they’ll
get flattened instantly if they let me get to
20 lands. Even if you own a card and it’s sitting
right there in front of you waiting to get added,
in a casual EDH group it might still be correct to
leave it out for the sake of keeping the deck at a
consistent power level. As mentioned earlier,
if you’re running a graveyard-centered deck,
you could juice up the power level of your
graveyard synergies, but if you’re not prepared to
deal with heavy-duty hate cards, you’re just going
to be running a mess of a deck that smashes fun,
casual decks but gets demolished at the
first sight of a Relic of Progenitus.
And, to bring things back to the earlier
points, if you’re running just the most
powerful of a certain effect like ramp,
removal, or draw, you’re going to have a
handful of games where you get those and
pop off super hard, and other games where
your deck is a clunky mass of high-cost synergy
cards that fails to accomplish much of anything.
But the bottom line is, if you
have a time machine and several
million dollars for bribes, we
should go back in time together
and prevent Wizards of the Coast from
printing Sol Ring in Commander 2011.